so the whole point of this exercise of
course is not to in some way stop a
future Insurrection it's to stop anybody
who opposes Biden from organizing ever
for example the FBI recently labeled a
veteran-led Disaster Response
organization a domestic terror group
that's according to an FBI whistleblower
The Disaster Response organization is
called American contingency Mike Glover
founded it he's the host of the mic
Force podcast he's a former Green Beret
and CIA contractor he joins us tonight
Mike Glover I appreciate your coming on
yeah thanks for having me so um do you
believe that you have been targeted by
the Department of Justice absolutely I
mean American contingencies started with
a concept after the Seattle mayor told
Law Enforcement Officers to not do their
job so it's a form of American citizens
who are depending and leaning on each
other in the absence of people including
politicians and law enforcement agencies
following the politicians and not doing
their job
so you spent your most of your life
working under arms for the US government
on behalf of the country how does it
feel to be targeted by that same
government it's horrible I mean look I'm
an entrepreneur first that's what I
wanted to do after a long time of
service and it just sucks being targeted
by you know a country
um my mom was targeted my mom's Facebook
account was deleted because the FBI
communicated to social media and and
destroyed all the social media accounts
my mom came here from Korea from meeting
my military dad in the Army and we're
dealing with this she's dealing with
this her small beauty salon in
Fayetteville North Carolina is dealing
with this
it's beyond belief in the fact that the
people whose job it is to defend you in
the Constitution are ignoring it really
grates on me
is there anything that we don't know I
mean are you accused of an actual crime
that you haven't told us about no so the
way it worked is I was labeled a
militant violent extremist organization
uh thank God organizations like project
Veritas exist they leaked this
information and FBI whistleblower came
out and said this is indeed true and not
only that but the FBI looked into Mike
Glover's records I'm a retired former
Special Operations guy a sergeant major
have a you know impeccable career have
done nothing wrong have never broken any
laws and they went into my career went
into my DD214 went into my Med records
and luckily somebody in the FBI likely a
FBI hostage rescue guy that I work with
overseas did a report and said hey this
guy's on the up and up I don't know why
you're looking in this guy but cease and
desist and that's how the traffic was
verbalized on a forum within the FBI so
it's not it's something that I thought
it was a rumor because I was getting
suppressed and deleted
canceled off of every social media
platform but it wasn't it was actually
something that was true so do you
recognize these tactics from the war on
terror that you fought in yeah like if
we're talking about subversion sabotage
if we're looking at uh government
entities going after its citizens these
are the first precursors to operational
prepare the environment we call it
shaping the environment and I don't like
seeing it as somebody who served a very
long time who wants to live in peace
many of my teammates Tim Kennedy Chad
robishaw Jack Carr we're all
entrepreneurs I just want to leave a
free life and be left alone yes and all
of these guys have their own little
nuances and stories of how they're going
after especially on social media and it
typically roots in Foundation back to
the US government shocking shocking
thank you for explaining that yeah and I
hope you'll tell us what happens thank
you subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight